I read while we sleep and I've listened
to a bunch of podcast episodes about
this but I just love to get your take on
a few of these like frequently asked
questions about sleep the first one that
comes to mind is
six hours seven hours eight hours nine
hours what what's going on there I think
the key thing for me is that one issue
size doesn't fit all and uh one of the
sort of slight frustrations that's
emerged is that an average value is
taken as the optimum value for all of us
and of course it isn't across adults for
example healthy sleep can range from six
hours maybe slightly less than that
um out to 10 or 11 hours and so yes
there is an average but actually there's
so much individual variation it's really
I think wrong to impose a specific
amount for each of us and the point of
the book to some extent is to allow
people to Define what's optimal for them
how do I do that how do you do that so
how do you know if you're not getting
when I sleep well it's you know it's the
kind of things our grandparents probably
would have told us if asked that
question which is that do you need a
partner or an alarm clock to wake you up
in the morning warning does it take you
a long time to wake up do you crave
caffeinated and sugar-rich drinks during
the day to keep you awake have your
friends family colleagues reported that
you're showing a lack of empathy
increased frustration they may have
noticed that you do stupid and
unreflective things and when given the
opportunity to sleep let's say at the
weekend and very notably on holiday do
you find your sleep patterns change and
it's really defining what each of us
needs and then trying to adopt behaviors
that defend that sleep pattern and you
know we know for example that the
duration of sleep varies enormously
between individuals but not only that
their timing going back to the molecular
clock there are subtle changes which can
make you a morning person or an evening
person but also going going back to
light that can contribute to what's
called your chronotype your morningness
and eveningness so morning light
advances the clock make you makes you
get up earlier evening light delays the
clock makes you get up later and go to
bed later so our sleep timing is
dependent upon our genetics and when we
see light but also there's another
factor which is how old we are so from
about the age of 10 there's a tendency
to want to go to bed later and later and
later peaks in lateness in males about
21 21 and a half in females about 19 so
men tend to be later for longer and then
as we age we sort of move to a more
morning chronotype the time we're in our
late 50s early 60s we're getting up and
going to bed at about the time we got up
and went to bed when we were 10 and that
actually changed almost perfectly
correlates with the changing levels of
estrogen and testosterone so that sharp
rise during puberty and then the sort of
decline in into old age so the point I'm
making is that not only is there lots of
differences between individuals in terms
of their their preference for how long
they want to sleep and when they want to
sleep but it changes as we age therefore
it's completely Daft to try and Define
the optimum sleep duration you must get
eight hours I think it was kicking back
against that and which was one of the
reasons for writing the book hey friends
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click here for
the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye